[Music]
welcome back so we're talking about the
Gabor transform and how you can use it
to compute the spectrogram which is a
time frequency diagram that you can use
to decompose audio signals not just into
their their power spectrum of what
frequencies are active but how that
power spectrum evolves in time to give
kind of this rich evolving audio signal
and in this lecture I'm going to show
you how to code this up in Python and
analyze a couple of interesting signals
okay good okay excellent so this is from
Chapter two of our book data-driven
science and engineering and all of this
Python code these jupiter notebooks were
made by Daniel doe loose key modified
from our MATLAB code so thank you Daniel
and this is the spectrogram code for a
chirp signal okay so in Python it's
pretty simple to build an audio signal
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
have an audio signal with a delta T of
0.001 so one kilohertz sampling we're
going to define the time from zero to
two so two seconds of audio and I'm
gonna have essentially an audio signal
which is going to go from a low
frequency 50 Hertz tone to a high
frequency 250 Hertz tone in kind of a
quadratic chirp pass okay that's what
this this function here does is that it
evolves in time going from low frequency
to high frequency I'm going to play the
sound here using this SD play code here
and you'll have to import sound device
as SD for this and then we're just we're
going to plot the spectrogram so the
spectrogram is basically one line of
Python code here where you show kind of
these different these different
arguments it basically shows you kind of
how why do you want this Gabor window to
be what's the sampling rate of the
original signal and how much overlap in
Delta T's should each of these Gabor
windows have and there's fancier
arguments you know to use different
Gabor windows for example you can use
this Gabor Windows is a Gaussian you
could use square windows and and all
kinds of other windows and you can use
those as arguments of the spectrogram so
check out the documentation if you want
to get under the hood of how to do this
this is just kind of a simple version
and once you generate that chirp you can
plot the spectrogram and it looks like
this okay so I'm just actually gonna run
this code okay so the pythons not
playing the sound nearly as nicely as
MATLAB but it went from low frequency to
high frequency boom like that so low
frequency to high frequency and you can
see here so the x-axis is time the
y-axis is kind of the frequency and the
intensity tells you how much power is in
each of those frequencies so here you
have kind of at 50 Hertz at x 0 there's
a lot of power in 50 Hertz and as time
evolves the power shifts up to higher
and higher frequencies up to 250 free
Hertz so it goes from low frequency boom
it's a high frequency and so this is a
nice way of visualizing kind of that
audio signal as it evolves in time ok so
the next example I'm going to show you
is pulling this beethoven sonata again
you can use this lib Rossa package to
load the file and this is gonna take a
couple of seconds so while it's loading
I'm going to show you in the data book
right so this is the chirp example I
just showed you if you did not compute
this time frequency diagram but instead
you computed the actual full Fourier
transform of the whole audio signal all
at once and computed the power spectrum
this is what you would get ok so here
you see that there is a lot of power at
50 Hertz and then there's a lot of power
and all of this band from 52 to 50 but
it doesn't tell you kind of where in
time these frequencies occur and so I
think it's kind of fun to take this and
knock it over on its side down here and
you can actually see now that the power
spectrum of the full audio signal is
kind of the cumulative average of
spectrogram averaged over time so if you
take the spectrogram an average up every
column you get back the power spectrum
of the full audio signal so you can see
that the reason most of the power is at
50 Hertz is because this was a quadratic
chirp so it spent the most time here at
50 Hertz most of the time was spent
right here at 50 Hertz and then less and
less and less time at each of the
subsequent frequencies okay so that's
why you see this kind of peak at 50
Hertz here and this is neat so what you
can think of as the spectrogram is
almost like an exploded view of the
power spectrum of the full signal so all
of the frequency content is in the power
spectrum the spectrogram tells you where
in time those frequencies occurred okay
okay so I think that my Beethoven has
loaded yes and now I'm going to plot the
spectrogram of the first million entries
so this is highly sampled and I think 24
kilohertz or something like that maybe
44 kilohertz a really really high
sampling rate and so I'm gonna plot the
first a million data points which i
think is about 40 I guess 45 seconds of
data here and on the x-axis we have time
up to about 45 seconds on the y-axis we
have frequency up to about 11 kilohertz
and again the color the intensity tells
you how much power how much audio power
is in each of those frequencies at each
instant in time and so these really
bright yellow Peaks correspond to
individual keys being played in this
progression in time as the as the the
audio goes on okay so I just love the
spectrogram I love how how much
information there is how how much you
can do with the spectrogram you could
take the spectrogram and you could take
the SVD of it and you can see what is
kind of the eigen cords that are being
played in this Sonata I think that would
be super interesting I encourage you to
do that see kind of what are the one of
the chord structures by taking the SVD
of this you could use that for
classification and all kinds of other
things
okay these are rich features of this
audio signal that you wouldn't get if
you just took the Fourier transform of
the whole thing okay
and if you look at this lib Rosa it
doesn't only give you the signal why it
also gives you the sampling rate so the
sampling rate is 20 mm or 22 kilohertz
the size of this data is about what is
this this is about 26 million entries so
that tells you that this is a really
long song this is like maybe 8 minutes
or something like that not sure I did
that math right maybe it's more like
maybe it's more like 20 minutes it's a
long song and I can play the first
30,000 M elements right here using this
okay that ran that let's run this okay
that was a little too short let me make
it a little longer you can see the
different progressions I'll make it a
little longer stone and then while this
is playing I'll show you a neat part of
the book okay so this is the first some
seconds of this and this is one of my
favorite diagrams we made in the book
which is essentially taking the first
two bars of this sonata up here and then
plotting below the spectrogram of the
first first 40 seconds of these first
two bars okay and for example you can
take these these boxed regions these
orange and blue boxed regions and you
can see what they look like in sheet
music and what they look like in the
spectrogram so for example here this
progression down here you can actually
see it in the in the spectrogram and as
zoom in if you zoom in to about the
first kilohertz the first thousand Hertz
of this this signal you can actually
color code each key on the piano and
this kind of rainbow pattern here so you
can see the CB beef b-flat and all of
these all of these keys and you can see
first of all that this piano is in tune
so the the the kind of bright spots
aligned with these keys but you can also
see the progression
of what keys are being played at what
point in time and the chords and so on
and so forth okay up here you can
actually see like harmonics and you know
resonances and all kinds of interesting
stuff so if you go to the code I think
this is probably in my MATLAB version of
the code you can see how I generate
these frequencies and and kind of make
these graphics and and how you can dig
into the spectrogram using the short
time Fourier transform okay but the
upshot here is that the spectrogram is
an extremely rich and powerful tool for
the analysis of evolving temporally
evolving signals so signals that are not
strictly speaking periodic but have
periodic structure evolving in time and
you can break this down into this time
frequency diagram which has lots and
lots of information ok so I encourage
you to play around with this you know
pick your own favorite song or audio
signal see if you can classify you know
jazz versus rock versus blues just based
on features from the spectrogram ok all
right thank you